bonsoir pierre-henri net bonjour avec
nous nous avons eu l'occasion il y a
quelques jours un d'évoquer la situation
dramatique de ces migrants à calais il
faut qu' on en arrive à des grèves de la
faim pour que l'état envoie un médiateur
goûtez y ait une situation qui dure
depuis près de 20 ans a calé et tout
simplement parce que vous avez un
certain nombre de gens là qui viennent
d'irak de syrie
qui viennent du yémen
et qui veulent se rendre en
grande-bretagne alors il ya eu des
épisodes successifs
sangatte qu'elle est calé dans je vous
rappelle qui a été évacué le camp de
calais qui a été évacuée il ya cinq ans
dix mille personnes est aujourd'hui
toujours des gens qui se concentre sur
le littoral calaisien pour rejoindre la
grande bretagne le problème est le
suivant c'est que évidemment les
autorités le maire de kehl et ne veulent
surtout pas de la reconstitution d'un
camp il ya une offre de logement qui est
proposé aux
migrants aux demandeurs d'asile qui sont
là bas mais qui n'est pas toujours
acceptés qui n'est pas toujours en
nombre suffisant et donc les ont pas
toujours accepté cette importance que
vous nous dites parce que c'est vrai
corps évidemment on n'a pas la
connaissance du terrain comme vous
l'avez on se dit on et laisse là on leur
propose rien donc vous le dites il ya
vraiment des des solutions alors via des
propositions qui sont faites évidemment
d'hébergement mais qui se situe à 100 km
200 km 300 kilomètres de calais or le
but et migrants s'est passé de l'autre
côté en grande beauté et puis je précise
j'ai j'insiste là dessus il n'y a pas
suffisamment de place de proposer et
donc vous avez une mission qui est donné
à la police qui est en permanence
d'empêcher toute reconstitution de caen
donc ça donne évidemment des tensions et
le grand problème c'est
de
de réussir à respecter la dignité des
personnes et les règles d'admission sur
le territoire le problème est le suivant
aussi c'est que la grande bretagne a
externalisé sa politique migratoire à
sous traiter sa politique migratoire à
la france et donc ça donne ces tensions
mais vous d'ailleurs
ça mais oui bien sûr bien sûr il ya des
traités qui ont été qui sont
continuellement révisé et il ya de
l'argent sonnant et trébuchant qui est
donné
pour
pour sécuriser
l'ensemble de la frontière mais qu'est
ce qu'il faut faire puis vous savez pour
ces migrants est temps de passer de
l'autre côté est-ce que c'est avec de
l'argent vers france va réussir à gérer
cette caisse b la france n'y arrive pas
mais je vais vous dire il y a un
problème à toutes les frontières dans
l'espace monde il ya une crispation
autour des territoires nationaux c'est
vrai à la frontière polonaise avec la
biélorussie
c'est vrai on lippi c'est vrai en italie
avec les gens qui viennent justement de
libye de tunisie etc c'est vrai partout
et
une des solutions c'est d'ouvrir des
voies de migration légale pour par
exemple
les mineurs qui arrive à calais il y en
a un qui ont de la famille de l'autre
côté et plutôt que de leur faire courir
le risque de
risque et le risque de leur vie dans la
manche sur des rafiots
d'entretenir des passeurs nous avions
essayé et moi personnellement il ya cinq
ans nous avions négocié avec le
gouvernement britannique
une voie de migration légale je crois
qu'il n'y a pas d'autre solution lui
faut rappeler les parents donc ça a
donné quoi aujourd'hui avec les brics là
bas ça a donné que tout s'est arrêté et
que le break si tu étais un énorme bond
sauge parce que je vous rappelle que le
break site a été vendu à la population
britannique sur l'idée il y aura plus de
migration oui mais sauf que depuis le
début de l'année il y a dix huit mille
personnes qui ont tenté le passage le
passage et dans des conditions
extrêmement difficiles il y a des morts
chaque chaque mois a calé les frontières
font
mourir un certain nombre de personnes y
a pas de solution simple donc mais il y
a des droits il ya un droit inaliénable
à demander l'asile et par exemple a calé
il ya des gens qui peuvent demander
l'asile en grande bretagne la grande
bretagne se paye de mots par exemple au
moment de la crise en afghanistan j'ai
entendu boris johnson expliqué que
d'aller cueillir vingt mille réfugiés en
provenance d'afghanistan bravo mais
juste de l'autre côté de la frontière il
ya des gens qui attendent et qui ont des
droits à faire valoir
de l'autre côté donc il ya ce qu'ils
vont prendre la part à leur part c'est
britannique n'est pas écouté et
manifestement il semble pas décidé à le
faire avec la france puisqu'ils
considèrent qu'il paie et mais l'europe
l'union européenne fait la même chose
dès que la turquie parce que erdogan
joue évidemment de la pression des
migrants sur l'union européenne mais la
pologne fait la même chose et la
biélorussie fait la même chose en
prenant en otage un certain des milliers
de migrants qui sont aujourd'hui dans
des forêts frontière donc c'est une
espèce de figure
planétaire avec laquelle
nous avons à faire et donc voilà nous
avons le choix de la dignité et du
respect des règles et je pense que nous
pouvons faire les deux voilà parce que
aujourd'hui ce qui se passe du côté de
kehl et
c'est une certaine forme d'un dignité ce
n'est pas possible de
continuer comme ça d'abord parce que
c'est inefficace vous savez le passage
pour aller vers la grande bretagne c'est
aujourd'hui 2000 2500 euros pour risquer
sa vie sur un rafiot pour aller 17 km de
l'autre côté et plus vous fermez plus
les routes migratoires
sans chérissent donc voilà oui c'est
normal qu'un état donne un certain
nombre de règles mais je crois qu'il
doit toujours avoir en tête le respect
de la dignité des personnes merci
beaucoup à verser
merci votre invitation